today marks and this is only because
it's 2020
the 10th major league debut for a
philadelphia phillies player with adonis
medina making the start this afternoon
shoots it to right but
a fair ball
it has been called a fair ball and
biggio's going to come around to third
and beshette is at second
and we'll want to get another look at
that one it must have hit the glove of
boom before bouncing into foul territory
which as you could see we couldn't see
but
the oscar hitting over 306th in the
league
he boxed he sure did they're going to
get a gift run
a buck called on medina
one nothing toronto
you gotta do it though
one two lifted in the air to right field
it's not deep the wind will push it foul
bomb is there makes the catch tagging
from third is machete now he holds up
and that's a good job infield's been
drawn in troy lourdes gorilla jr the
batter
and a ground ball will sneak through off
the glove of gregorius into left guriel
with an rbi single in the blue jays lead
two to nothing
swinging a miss and his first major
league strikeout comes at a 93 mile an
hour fastball taiwan walker will make
his fifth start as a blue jay he's 28
years old and he had a very abbreviated
outing last time out those strikes are
good
and he got him walker strikes out
mccutcheon one down
to left field and catching up to it is
gorielle to make the catch on the edge
of the track out number two first man to
reach for the phillies that'll bring up
the shortstop didi gregorius
in the air to right field going back on
it is hernandez and it is off the top of
the scoreboard played it into a run one
run will score ball will cross the plate
the throw goes to second rbi double for
dede eight double of the year it's a 2-1
game
got him
so a couple of strikeouts in the inning
for taiwan walker so a big opportunity
here the base is loaded with one out for
beau bechet
a little tapper in front of the plate
medina is coming in he flips with his
glove he gets the out at home and that's
a good play
back to the middle under the hand of
medina and it's picked up by kingry
hopefully it went under his hand
there he is had so much extra popcorn
this year
he doesn't know what to do with it he's
spilling it everywhere all over the
cutouts
watch out matt oh no
oh he's falling down oh excuse me
that'll happen here
he could be entertaining and a totally
empty statement yep yeah not me it's a
cut out
yeah he pointed to one of the cutouts
[Applause]
hit well out to right center field roman
quinn jumps and he made the catch
and one out here in the fifth inning
sorry about that murph that ball sounded
like it was going to go pretty far i
know he's gotten some strikeouts with
his fastball up
but that fastball down is a good pitch
deep to right field ante oscar makes the
catch and then comes up hobbling
might have gotten his foot caught in the
fence
out in front of the scoreboard and
hopefully nothing serious it's the right
foot yeah you see how he kicked the
bottom of that base yeah
and he's waved away montoya along with
ministral so the manager and the trainer
appear to be convinced that oscar
hernandez is okay he just flashed just a
thumbs up
now he's telling his teammates will you
get out of here please i'm going to be
fine that's blatty you know bladdy said
something funny so a big spot here
runner a third one out the phillies have
brought the infield in and the batter is
vladimir guerrero junior
ground ball to third segura he applied a
tag safe at third and the throw across
the diamond to first in time to get
guerrero
what a heads up play by segura
i mean that was close and you know you
talk about
let's see if jonathan davis can produce
davis has walked and struck out first
and third two down two on blue jays
and davis hits a ball hard to left field
and it's going to be over the head of
hazley and up against the wall
glorielle has scored panics in behind
him and how about jonathan davis coming
up with another big hit
the 3-2 pitch that's hitting the air out
to deep left field guriel going back got
turned around and that ball is caught
caught by guriel the runner was around
second on his way back sagura will reach
without a throw
what a play by lourdes gorilla junior
and even he is exhaling after running
that drive down from the bat of hazley
had it all away
puts the ball in play and hits it well
to right center field and it's off the
top of the fence and karim's away from
the outfielders and bows around second
and on his way into third with a triple
i don't know if harper's got a little
something going on or if he's just
stretching out there so a triple for
boba shed blue jays will look to add to
the lead with t oscar hernandez at the
plate the right hander deals the 3-0
green light for hernandez and he jolts
one straight away center field and gone
an absolute rocket from the bat of te
oscar hernandez screaming over the wall
in straight away center field a two run
no doubter 6-1 blue jays here in the
seventh
3-2
and a swing and a miss got him to chase
a fastball for out number one
well remember that stretch we saw bryce
harper doing in the outfield and inning
ago we wondered is he just stretching or
is there something going on he might be
done he might have just taken himself
out of the game with something here's
where alec can't get himself out either
tapper over the mound off the glove of
hatch picked up by paddock he throws to
first pass guerrero one run is in here
comes the second run as marshawn scores
the throw to second in time to get
bombed
back to the mound bass has it and the
blue jays pick up a much needed win